all right and your immersion we grow as
a city roads are oh I smell talent
called Pleasant Bella it's a suburb tell
me what your chocolate you grow up with
both parents one parents ice talent both
parents and they got an abortion I'm not
see grew up with my mom and how was your
shoulder crappy I never happy child
abuse most of my parents in China I lost
my chin repaired
they'd abused in my home on to by my
father that's why my hurts not divorce
actually yes Jim I waited and five and
six years old and what kind of stuff
could happen or upset a finger and my
vagina yeah every day right what
happened and we were well loved by my
mother but I really had very few threats
and I was very lonely very lonely I had
them on my farm I do I have these
- in my adult life I've been of my
champio to social month and my dog mom
oh I see I've been down here since
December 2013 thousand right - yeah
prymaat kids of your own
I have a wrong son than my sober light
did you raise him no my parents right -
and so what is your drug your honesty
yeah I thought I was up to 11 beer and
spice
what is spice do for you Oh like like
marijuana extra strike I miss my and if
I get Best Buy sites like bedbugs they
die immediately and where do you sleep
at night
I love over here I have an anger
residence but no no toilet or shower
over here on town Avenue so yeah you
actually had a room yeah I have a robot
don't told her a shout okay
yeah yeah all right I might be Fred I
have a place a door yeah with you what
do you do for money I'll go on that's
outside no my mom passed away so you're
kind of on your own though
she's not my best to win two dozen
everybody yeah brave man you're gonna
have to be friends I have a few friends
no family
I'm happy with that how do you spend
your days what do you what'd you do
hey thanks I'm not dead right cities I
had to read my Bible how often do you do
smoke spice every day
is that the was the first rope you
strike I Drive alcohol then it meant not
cigarettes tobacco pit for it then back
home yeah Dabangg college conservative
drug Brian have you have you tried
cocaine or heroin or another question
man I have tried cocaine before all
right everyone time to go where there's
been four I meant I got cracked rope oh
oh is that I thought no violence at
Thank You sighs I'll try Harlem back
Maya thank you so much for talking to me
and yeah good luck with everything out
there Claudia is there